[Music]
perfect
with this
i'll be able to cut dimitri out of the
cracked universe
no more
cs go and tack shooters
ah that must be the script for this week
i wonder what it's about
oh what the [ __ ]
okay there's no denying that valorent
shares a few similarities with
counter-strike
okay more like a lot of similarities but
when it comes down to straight up
copying valve's homework riot managed to
screw up the whole just change it up a
bit so it doesn't look obvious rule i
say that because basically every gun in
valoran is just a rip-off of a cs go
weapon he copy my whole [ __ ] flow
word for word
the classic is the glock the sheriff is
the deagle the vandal is the ak hell the
bulldog is basically just the famas and
the golil frankenstein together but when
it comes to riots dollar store dupes no
two weapons are more alike in premise
than the op and
well the op whether it's the big green
or whatever the hell this is the premium
bolt action snipers both play a similar
role they're both high risk high reward
typically one shot one kill and
absolutely control the battlefield when
in the right hands
seemingly a three on two a five on two
right every single time still winnable
falling needs the ace clutch he's got
two
oh come on falling yeah the blood's
flowing now fall on another oh it gets
sick
and
what can they even do they make their
way on site no
and everything tends with an ace all
that being said they aren't completely
identical while on the surface they may
appear to be the same weapon when you
get into the nitty gritty they couldn't
be more different so luckily for all of
you and
probably unluckily for me that nitty
gritty is exactly what we're gonna get
into we're here to find out exactly
which one of these boomsticks is better
than the other how simple nerfs changed
the course of both games forever and
most importantly
should anything be changed
[Applause]
oh right i guess since i'm hosting this
video this is the part where i have to
tell you to like and sub and all that
stuff so
do that i guess
thanks now it's no secret that i've
basically made a career off of talking
about the
oh wait hold on a second that's a
dimitri line i can't say that
by most accounts counter-strike's op is
the deadliest most iconic and dare i say
sexiest weapon in esports it's the most
straightforward gun in the whole game
yet it has an impressively high skill
ceiling that's why those who are able to
master it are considered gods on the
server and from 1.6 to global offensive
the big stick has been responsible for
some of the most legendary plays in the
franchise's history nasty stuff but
simple's gonna get himself oh
that
is something special over devices even
here to help out and now
while it is good for one they give it
the respect to get back to the car that
might be their undoing the short play
now from twist oh device reads it in
with the flick burning alive and the
collateral in the flames the ace for
device
and 31 seconds nitro changes that with
the first and the second looking he gets
a third looking for the fourth doesn't
even matter at this point stewie's on it
nitro has gotten that point what a round
of the awp
but in april of 2020 riot made a bid to
challenge cs go's fps supremacy and
every long-range lover wondered if they
could make a sniper that would match the
ecstasy the op produces and in some
aspects it did the operator is loud and
when wielding it you can really feel its
power valorent's op is genuinely badass
when put in the right hands
holy [ __ ]
what a chad are you kidding me has been
able to show up
he's uh i got another kill paint up mw1
oh sk rossy three kills four this is
huge from sk rossi and he's looking for
every single victim sk ross he's got the
it when it comes to these after plant
scenarios it can be
the lymph nodes go from yummy
the fin is just going flashy at this
stage now while the operator does
capture a lot of the aesthetic of the
awp statistically there's a bit more of
a difference and a lot of that
difference boils down to three different
things rounds per minute scope speed and
movement for those who have played or
watched both games it's not hard to
notice that cs goes op is much more
capable of producing multiple kills in a
round
because it does you see currently the cs
go op can shoot 41 rounds per minute
valorent's operator only has an rpm of
36 now that might not seem like a lot
but when we slow it down you can really
see the difference the exact same can be
said about the time to scope in as well
for those not aware both snipers aren't
accurate until scoped all the way in and
standing completely still and for the
operator it feels like an eternity in
comparison these differences seem minute
but at most levels of the game those
milliseconds make all the difference
devices had a really rough game flashed
he's gonna get that shot and it has to
feel a little bit good out middle of the
air to take down alex and now they're
pushing
oh takes every single one
from nothing to the awps
but the speed of both weapons isn't
everything we also need to talk about
movement and valerian is very very slow
in comparison to cs go whether it's slow
walking or side strafing the game can
feel a little lethargic and when
directly compared to cs go it's night
and day and as our pal the war owl
pointed out the movement speed reduction
in valorem while getting shot at is
insane and when you do hit them they get
tagged hard tagging is when a player is
slowed after they get shot it's so
extreme invalid that simply getting hit
will stop you immediately regardless of
what weapon you got hit with regardless
of what weapon you're carrying and
regardless of if you had shields or not
if you engage in enemy invalorant you
need to go for the shot every single
time you cannot escape this makes it
very difficult for operators to
reposition themselves after their first
shot without getting overwhelmed yes the
operator is still very good at holding
angles and stopping pushes but due to
its slower stats it makes getting
follow-up kills much more difficult the
valor op is
is only good for
like you know picks it's really not that
viable for
peaking as much uh every time you peek
you're gonna need a flash you're gonna
need whatever and then that's why you
don't see like
really insane uh op clips all the time
but it's such a boring weapon in this
game i really i really don't like how
clunky the op is i don't like how the
movement is i really dislike it
to the point was you know now i'm
playing soba and i and i don't mind
never having to touch an object in this
game don't get me wrong opening kills
are one of the most important stats in
both valorent and cs go but putting that
level of investment into a one-for-one
trade isn't optimal zywu and simple
aren't the best players in the world
just because they can get opening picks
with the op it's the second third fourth
and yes fifth kills that they get in
succession that allow them to control
the server and simple he needs a
multi-kill first found twist aggressing
they have to double peak he's getting
his shots he's hitting another one
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again however at valorance
launch there was one outlier that
negated the sluggish nature of the
operator and valerian as a whole
jet you see jet has the ability to yield
herself in any direction which allows
her to get quick picks and reposition
as a result this made jet one of the
only viable options for op users riot
has been criticized for their decision
to basically lock the most important
weapon in the game to a specific agent
so that's why the the op is mainly only
viable for people who have uh get out of
jail abilities right there are ages
different sets and combos of util and
variety right but now we've locked down
three big roles on the majority of the
maps the only real
variability comes in oh what kind of
sentinel do you want oh what kind of
what kind of flex player do you want you
know
and like that doesn't really uh it it
really truncates that like the depths
that is possible with with the 18
different agents now the operator and
the awp are fairly close in cost while
the economy in cs go is a lot larger but
this doesn't excuse the operator's
statistical shortcomings or the
existence of the jet meta three versus
five with 50 seconds and attends in your
face he's gonna find his third get the
aids tags i'm ready for another
highlight clip the ultimate is still
available for zops that's the only thing
that i can see in their favor i'm just
gonna shut up and watch tens for a
little bit okay all right they're giving
them the opportunity for the ace and
there it is but before we get too
carried away with the statistics we need
to remember that both these iconic
sniper rifles have undergone some not so
small changes in their own histories
they each received nerfs that not only
changed the way the gun worked but how
the games would be played around them
back in 2015 the cs go ops scope
movement speed was slowed now that might
not seem like a big change but if you
think it's overpowered now remember
kenny s used to do [ __ ] like this on the
daily just to get out the exposed
position picks up the frag onto aloo
goes for the quick second shot forest is
causing oh my goodness so much damage
done here by kenny yes another five
pound and again kenny s four kills in a
row
comes kenny s oh my god kenny s with
three insane kills now players
eventually adapted and most of the drama
has died down since the nerf but at the
time it did drastically affect the way
some players used the gun especially on
t side that being said
the op still
and split towards people
one shot connecting no
you can't do that ridiculous the
operator however is another story in the
early days of valorum the op was a lot
different in fact it was downright
broken
changes to the operator definitely
needed to be made no one really argued
otherwise but what we weren't expecting
was an entire rework the price was
increased by 500 credits scoped movement
speed was reduced along with the rate of
fire and the return to accuracy after
moving was cut in half by almost all
margins this was an entirely new gun it
was so drastic that riot's lead agent
designer had to preface the patch notes
so people wouldn't freak out
look how they messed with my boy now we
are talking about gamers so people did
freak out but a lot of pros actually
welcome this change feels more balanced
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie feels
more balanced
i'll admit it
did a good job nicholas wu so to make a
long story short the awp is just the
more effective gun when compared with
the operator to give you an idea of just
how much more effective let's take a
look at some of the weapon stats from
the 2021 pgl major and valor in
champions 2021 at pgl the op was used
11.58 percent of the time and it hovers
around that margin at most major lan
events but the operator's popularity was
only 5
at champions that's below the classic
and the ghost it's also no coincidence
that many of cs go's greatest players
have also been primary operas the
significance of the role it plays cannot
be understated the operator on the other
hand just isn't quite there the awp
raises the hair on your neck it makes
fans jump out of their seats and it's
the reason cs go is one of the most high
octane games to watch there's twists
poking his head out in the toilet so i
will trade another clutch maybe
on the site cold hiding behind the truck
and now zai wu dancing left and right
he's got to pick his shot wisely he's
only got one chance
oh
oh my goodness and all of this brings us
to our final question
should anything be changed are we just
okay with the operator playing the role
that it does well it depends on how you
look at it in cs go there will always be
detractors who think the awp is
overpowered and yes it can be annoying
but your whole team should have a
plethora of utility to counter it in
valorent it's not that simple only
specific agents get smokes and flashes
to deal with the operator and as reddit
users sociopathic frogs argued you spend
almost all that utility on a jet with an
operator but like i mentioned earlier
this isn't an accident by riot
or at least not exactly
riot clearly didn't want their game to
revolve around the operator so they
nerfed it into the ground but with those
changes they created a whole new problem
with jet but riot isn't stupid they saw
the issue and decided to fix it in the
most right way possible
adding a completely new agent
[Music]
you get a name
chamber
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about over the past few
months i've kind of become a chamber man
some like my editor keith might even
call me a one trick at this point he's
given me an excuse to pick up the
operator and i can still tell my
teammates that i'm being a team player
because he's technically a sentinel but
let's talk more about his ult by all
margins chamber result is basically the
cs go up it's faster than the valorem
operator in all aspects and his
rendezvous ability allows players to
peak angles and get to safety the same
way that jet would but who needs that
when your alt is this damn good
absolute catastrophe is yay finds
perfect timing
annihilates the entire team but why why
would riot make an agent with a better
version of the operator well it's simple
for the meta as much as riot doesn't
want their game to be centered around
one weapon they don't want it to be
centered around one agent either the
nurse that they made to jet just weren't
enough and thus chamber was born in
berlin jet had a pick rate of over 82
percent way more than any other agent
but since chamber and fracture came out
the pick rates have been a lot more
level but chamber isn't overshadowing
jet because he's new and shiny the
impact he has on the economy is actually
his main draw chamber in general it just
has
has a great
as the most economically efficient kit
really
all you need as a chamber right is to
make sure you have at least 4 200 which
you know is two trips and
uh armor and a rifle right and you don't
even buy shirt bullets until
um you know you can't afford a rifle i
feel like the chamber up is
in its own wedges just as overpowered as
jet knives actually you know probably
probably more of a powerful jet nice you
know it's like it's a lot easier to get
those one or two picks and it's very
easy to whiff with your jet knives to
help valrant's stats god ominous even
spelt it out for us with this graph as
you can see chamber mains are spending a
hell of a lot less than jet mains while
still providing solid damage output
jet's mobility still makes her an
extremely useful opera especially if you
want to be more aggressive but you can't
deny the appeal of a free op every five
or six rounds oh he puts it high up
hard left turn left i'm jen he's walled
off he can't go can't go deep can't go
deep
and that was the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about hold up how did
nile end up stealing my segment
is this what dimitri feels like when i
cut in on his script
the question remains what is riot going
to do going forward cs go is clearly
more comfortable with the meta that it's
built up over years of gameplay players
at all levels are generally much more
accepting of the role that the awp plays
within it but riot isn't the detached
absent father that valve is with cs as
new maps and agents come out the meta
will change
the road to balancing valorent will
undoubtedly be a long one even now riot
is working on another jet nerf
specifically to her tailwind ability for
patch 4.08 but we'll have to wait and
see if this has any major effects on her
strengths as an opera and even though
the awp is statistically better in its
own game the operator is still extremely
important to the fabric of valorem
whether you like it or not it will be a
massive factor in how the game evolves
in the future the only way they can buff
the op in this game in terms of like
speed and fire rate so that we can
actually start seeing like cool things
and have that and have the op actually
actually be more like the chamber up
where you can see like these incredible
multi frags right um
incredible miracle rounds right like the
simple rounds the coldzera rounds the
only way you're ever going to see that
is if they buff movement as well
because if they don't buff movement then
the op would just be way too
on him but you overpowered
dimitri's not better than me he's not
better than me
i could do this he's definitely better
than me he's a theater kid i can't i
can't top that
easy game easy game if you play right
boys
easy club
wow
i was like stub my toe on i might extend
and as reddit user sociopathic frogs
point argue i can't say
sociopathic frogs
esports ladies and gentlemen esports i
was gonna say i don't know who would
have an emotional attachment to the op
but i feel like dimitri is like the
poster child for having an emotional
attachment to a fictional gun yeah if
anyone in the office has an emotional
attachment to a
virtual
weapon
is this too cringe i can love a free up
smile